hello in this video i explain
what the variables are and how
you can easily create them online and
let's start right away as
independent variables or
projectors either metric or
categorical variables with two
characteristics can be used in your recession model what
we have to do  if we have more than two
characteristics, you will find out straight away
categorical variables with two characteristics
are also referred to as dicators
an example would be gender with the characteristics
male and female let's
say you have female coded 0 and
male with 1 in which case female would then be
the reference  category being if
we now take a look at the recession
model and let's say the variable
x1 is gender then b1 is the
regression sco efficient for
gender how can we interpret b1
we said 0 is female and one
is male so we put  that
just gle in the recessions  direction 1
female 0 and male 1 then
we have 0 x p1 for a female person
and once per 1 for a male person
accordingly b1 indicates the
difference between male and
female the slope is the
difference so let’s say we want
the income of a  person
predict so y is the income
if a person is male
they earn the same value as once more than a
female person let's say the
recession model comes out that b12 is
100 then this would mean that
men earn 200 euros on average more
than women
accordingly  do you want to predict the salary
of a person and this
person is male you get
the value 200 euros here a female
heard the value zero euros
here we have now discussed how we deal with
variables with two values
now let's look at what we do
if we have a variable with more than two
values, we say you mö  predict
the consumption of a car based
on its hp and the vehicle type
and let's say there are only three
vehicle types the sedan, sports car
and family choose
so the variable vehicle type has more
than two characteristics, in this case three characteristics can
result in a recession
model  but we only consider categorical
variables with two characteristics,
so the question now is what do we do
so that we can use categorical variables with
more than two characteristics in a
recession valley, we have to
create so-called dummy variables,
which means that we make three from our
variable with three characteristics  make new
variables, each with two characteristics
so we have our vehicle
types here with the characteristics sedan sports car
and family if now we
make a new variable from each characteristic so
we have the variable is it
a sedan is it a sports car and
is it a fan event  each of these three
variables  n has the values ​​0 and 1
or no and yes it is a
sedan yes or no is it a
sports car yes or no
or is it a family if yes or no
accordingly we previously had one
variable with three values ​​now
we have three variables with two each
characteristics what do we have to do now when
preparing our data
you originally have a column with the
vehicle type where the individual vehicles
from a random sample are listed
the first vehicle is a sedan
the second is an el houcine and the third is a
sports car and so on and so forth
get out of here  you now have three new
variables so you have a
column each for is the sports car's sedan
and is family band what is the first
car the first car tore a sedan
so let's
write 0 for the sedan is a 19 hp sports car and families
will also be exactly the same  for
the second car, let's say the third car is a
sports car, so for limousines we write
and  sports car 1 and s family
would be new again so we have now
formed our dummy variables there is
one more thing to note
there are always the number of
characteristics - an sda formed with variables
we must, for example, be sure that it is a
sedan
we know that it is not a family one,
for example that it is a sports car
we can also be sure that it is
not a family and if it is not a
limousine and not a sports car
then we are sure that it is a family
if it is accordingly we need
it  variable not because this
information is superfluous
so a minus 1 is always
formed for the variables so it is sufficient
if we have the lady variables is it a
sedan and is the sports car of
course you can set them against each other
we could just as well
omit the music and it  is to add family waves
and now i will show you how
you can easily online with data tab tami
vaud  countries can see
the budget easily on day.de click on
the statistics calculator if
you want to use your own
data click on table teachers and paste
your data here i
just use the example data
we want to calculate a regression
so we click on regression
i want to now  simply as a dependent
variable the income from and as an
independent variable the age and the
company
the company is a variable with
three characteristics bmw daimler and vw
accordingly we have to create dummy variables here
but datatec does this for you
alone if we go down
scrolling down to the results we see
that our model contains the age
bmw and daimler
so the dame variables bmw and daimler have already been
formed the third
training vw has been omitted and now
you can interpret your tables as usual
or you can look at the
summary in  answer
if i want your independent  variable
categorical but a dependent
variable then you have to calculate a logistic
recession for
this just watch my next video see you
soon